[Music]
coming at you live from the roof of the
Spreckels theater in downtown San Diego
it's live at Conan card featuring
comedians Joel Kim booster Flula Borg
and marina Franklin and now you're live
at Conan Con host Moses store hey guys
and welcome to live at Kona Con I'm
Moses storm and when I'm not walking the
Convention Center floor getting stopped
by Latvian teens with cataracts thinking
that I am King Joffrey from Game of
Thrones I'm the host of live at Kona Con
it's a touchdown show when all things
comic-con and things that Conan is doing
down here at the con everyday I have my
three correspondents out there grabbing
highlights just things that they like
from Comic Con and we go over them on
this show so please say hello to my very
funny correspondents Joel Kim booster
he's awake Flula Borg best dressed thank
you and my favorite that I say in front
of everyone
Marina Franklin thank you guys so much
for joining us I was about there today
oh oh so fun it was fun we got into more
things it was more people yeah it was
crowded and hot yes and we're smoky up
here who knows what kind of exhaust we
have anything could happen this is live
at Kona con make sure you're following
this show this is also known as the
white noise video that plays during the
comments section as they just comment
where's Conan where's Conan that right
now
both our dad Conan O'Brien welcome
dental Iveco nakhon thank you guys for
joining us
hey good to see thank you so much very
model set so okay the shitty ship hey
everybody how's it going hello Internet
hey Internet people
giant thank you to Andy with the first
swear of the show we've made it on today
yes I didn't have the mic near my eyes
no no I think pretty good I uh I had a
little key I have a little case of I
woke up this morning and had trouble
speaking and I thought it was not a
stroke it was turned out to be viral
laryngitis and I think it's from so much
talking but also just shaking hands with
hundreds of thousands of people so I
went to La Jolla oh wow and I turned and
II cuz Andy hangs out in La Jolla all
the time big La Jolla Romney's yeah Andy
is a pornographer on the side and he
makes a lot of his best work in La Jolla
and I went there and a doctor ran a
camera up my nose they had viral
anything camera time exactly we at least
we did three Snickers integrations while
the camera was up that was already in
there then they a guy came in with a
needle and jabbed me in the ass with it
the but sorry and then they put me on
all these other oral steroids
wait so where where do you go to get the
guy to come and put the he doesn't come
you got to go there oh you've got to go
to him and but it's a very sensual
experience you're not gonna rusty door
and you start screaming outside for 40
minutes and then he lets you in okay for
the show yeah but you know what some
women find it more attractive absolutely
yeah it's more Suzanne Pleshette
[Laughter]
e-everyone watching the live stream come
on guy
yeah so it was really fun we just in our
last show which is always a little
bittersweet cuz we love it's really fun
here yeah we fun and Andy brought a
surprise woman named Christina and she I
think on Facebook she's CC customs pop
and they did this last year to these
great fans made me these pop dolls that
are their custom one-offs for custom
one-off sorry and II feel bad for me
because they're the conan ones so i like
to call these my pity pops but you know
one we you know i think it's i think we
should do something about that there
should be a candy on andy pop if they're
gonna be a tiny ant-man there can be a
tiny yeah first to see of how i profit
from this okay first to see how this
helps me how does this and if it doesn't
then it's just gonna have to understand
I understand know how do you directly
pay for your visiting doctors right
exciting shots and cameras in your body
exactly but wait well normally worth
like three times more than the Conan
Pops because there's a butyl and hey
they ways much rare guess what things
yeah this is like a now a Home Shopping
Network
Andy is negan I think would go for as
much as I think this could easily go for
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
right now J eggs whereas yours are like
those eggs that pantyhose come in up to
this roof high on various drugs and
medications to be insulted yes look if
we're going up there I am gonna I'm
gonna s talk you I want to say something
positive yeah all right so I don't often
dukes I'm a very negative person yes I
just been watching your work all week
long you guys thank you : all have you
been doing an amazing job and really
just very proud like an old addled
out-of-touch father who is receding sort
of into the background
clean and who calls you by each other's
names yes frequently yes oh he like
mixes up the name yeah Joel yeah okay
his father's you know it's all um but
now I've just really they just they've
done an amazing job you've been all over
comic-con you've done really fun stuff
you have very funny sense of humor I'm
revealing my half sock you know I don't
know if that's appropriate for this
might excite people very few people have
seen the conan birthmark I tried to show
it the other day but had that my whole
life and when I was I was self-conscious
about as a child and my mom said you
shouldn't be that's where an angel
kissed you oh that's the reward for
being good I don't let an angel kiss you
is the moral of that story to kiss you
on the shin I don't know that's creepy I
didn't get into that and then later on
my brother told me that it was a devil
that threw acid on me leave it to Big
Brother's now I'm just confused the
world's first Internet comments is just
older brothers exactly
speaking of Internet you take a
comic-con citizenship test yes I did
every year every year and this is for
Andy - I have a this is a streaming show
a internet damn topsail ROTC there there
on Andy and I went every muster together
it's like you know Brangelina right when
it to it when we're apart it's not as
intense no we're together the amount of
attention that okay those are just
helicopters that are ads they're towing
yeah your cough drops that's right
they're just ads millennial who doesn't
get it
that's what they do the paparazzi's they
tow fake ads and they get pictures of
Andy and I canoodling and restaurants
says getting Andy's knees hotshot right
there get some like action from you guys
yeah well you know we can let our hair
down now that we're contractual we're
contractually our contractual obligation
is done is done
although still might go by Team Coco
house if I if these drugs hold up I'm
thinking to go by there I'm gonna try
and lick everybody in the back the room
yeah yeah you're truly going viral yes
which leads us to what you're gonna do
now yes I have some misspelled Internet
phrases on here as customary for the
internet so if you and Andy could could
do your best to tell me what these
Internet phrases mealeasy my very very
up on the lingo go yeah you guys took a
bird scooter up here sure so they're
pretty hip and young so the first one
the first Internet term tell me your
best and your best of your knowledge
what are you a priest at a Catholic Mass
there's a fly more bees are gonna be no
it was a fly he didn't step on a bee
people he's Darren pizza guy is flying
over
you got your picture yeah lovers I got
your bar out-of-focus photo okay so the
first Internet term this is a real
Internet term tell me what you think
this means if I was to say Conan you
extra you extra yeah you've got it going
on downtown your enhanced your I think
of you favorably yeah favorably like
yeah positive you're like other people
are medium but you're extra or other
people are medium/large you're extra so
I think it means that your X you're like
you're all that and a bag and you're
like kind of slightly crazy it means
you're like drama right how you say it
like went too much you're doing too much
too much oh that sound like an insult at
all insults insults should sound like
insight right you that's doesn't anyone
who doesn't right oh that's if you said
to me you hate sure I'd be like well
thank you yeah I haven't you know I like
extra yeah honestly you both are being
extra right now oh okay that brings us
to our Inc you this might be even a clue
guys wearing uh sneakers from in their
vintage there are 50s are you a shark or
a jet ones which is well first of all
Joel Kim is wearing those and those are
a cast of Footloose died in these shoes
yeah let's take you Larry nice and then
what are you wearing there Flula these
are made from disease are genes that
I've converted into sapatos okay you may
be the worst person I've ever met that
leads us to our next one throwing shade
oh I know what throwing shade is like
tie
why'd you throw shade and at China yeah
something like that
it's that's an insulting way to sort of
insult them throw shade at them but you
didn't you didn't actually get in their
face and say you know I hate you Moses
no I just what I do is it'd be like yeah
Moses on the roof that's really
something you want to catch and then I
threw shade at you overheard actually
today shockingly accurate yeah I read a
lot of tabloid blurbs so I know that one
a lot of people think that shade is just
an insult like you see a gets along a
lot of like oh you know Michelle threw
shade at Sarah by calling her the B word
and it's like no that's just an ins
that's an insult shade is an insult with
plausible deniability yeah like if you
were to if someone threw shade at me and
I tried to explain to my friend like my
marina said this thing to me I would
look insane try like if I said nice
blouse I really like your black guess
what you do have a nice blouse yes nice
okay this thing happened IRL what's this
IRL is a contraceptive device yes
no yes RL means in real life in real
life right like as opposed to your
virtual online friends they're your IRL
friends oh do you guys have IR else
inside now no I only exist as pixels and
you just yes
Flula only whenever he's not on the
Internet yes I'm the Mike your essence
punch out of humans yes you are just
you're just a smouldering fanny pack in
the corner and then when someone puts
you on the Internet you in the blue blue
blue blue blue feels like I just ate a
mushroom eyes yeah comes that would be
so great if you crawled into your own
fanny pack where you were being paid I
don't have the words gorgeous fanny pack
that's where I sleep oh I've seen it I'd
rather not see it okay so the next term
is BAE BAE BAE beautiful no that's a
this girl
is my beyond all else or something isn't
that like yeah but I thought it just
meant like oh my god she's BAE it's like
you're there but he's a little your most
important person in years yes so it
would be the acronym would be best
isn't it like before before all yep help
you all with all of these terms you know
what I didn't want to say that yes oh
here's the problem here's the dilemma if
I turn to you and say why don't you tell
us what that means then I'm yeah
component I Got News for you what you
did with your eyes yeah I was just
admiring I was admiring your blouse I
think purple is your power color it's my
bag I think though it sort of trickles I
mean the gay people steal it from black
women and then the rest of the internet
steals it from gay people and I learn it
on RuPaul's Drag Race exactly the path
of Apprendi have you heard this one on
RuPaul's Drag Race is our last term it's
FOMO yes that's beer of missing out like
that oh and I got one yeah oh then I've
been noticing lately clap back yes clap
backs a big one and people use it a lot
they clap back someone on the internet
some random person will body shame
Selena when she puts I mean
Selena Gomez when she puts out like a
picture of herself in a bikini but then
she claps back says I'm proud of my body
and I'm hoping that someone body shames
me because I want to clap that no one
cares
I walk around all the time in you know
shorts and bathing suits and no one
cares I want someone to body shame me so
I can clap back so then the Internet can
say yeah you go girl oh yeah yeah Conan
O'Brien has the weird
the world's weirdest birthmark on his
I was gonna say now that you've
shown the birthmark yeah and then listen
here's what I want to happen when that
happens I'm gonna clap back but then I
want you not you fool you're gonna screw
it up well I want you two to say like
yeah you go girl Conan owned his freckle
and he did what he had to do
and he he'll rewrite on that but yeah he
owned his freckle yeah
come on Lola you go girls you extra
that's it no more
what's that no good you got wordy after
the you go girl yoga yeah could you
trying to use them all instead dad you
did that go drop yo how about this um no
he didn't he didn't say that but he
didn't though right what do you mean he
did in awhile since when did you say it
when he did say it no I want someone to
say did he go there and then I want you
to say perhaps let's look at the map no
let's let's roll the tape back they
would he's very good at that he's you
guys want to leave us on one sentence
using all those terms yes you can so
recap there and he's not extra yeah he's
my he's my foam oh and if he ever he
ever Omo if he ever throws shade at me
I'm gonna clap back at him oh and you
guys are gonna have my back because of
there was another one in there IRL yeah
because I didn't insert my IRL yeah okay
well the meds have definitely kicked in
yeah yeah girl he did that he you know
yes and and you do it Flula it's
terrible just and I try to support you I
appreciate it sure you seem like a bad
guy
what are you lord what's happening
handing to look for something was a way
to fondle yourself okay if you want to
touch yourself oh oh Carmen and I are
gonna get into it again he's maybe
holding up that rap like these guys have
so much more to do my photos to show the
paparazzi got their shot of Conan with
his drugs oh wow
yeah methylprednisolone quick shout out
to our sponsors nothing for yzma i'm on
bringing racehorses down since noise
yeah okay I'm sorry I feel terrible
alright we have to leave now
if you put it in the other way oh not to
the tube
Oh No
just think of it as the universe that's
it goodbye everyone - bye everybody and
remember if you can do it then no one
can
right right follow your dreams yes into
an abyss yeah remember when they tell
you you can't do it they're probably
right well you should go thank thank you
thanks Andy thank you for stopping by
the show here's right do the bid ante
where it takes me a long time to leave I
enjoy it oh yeah okay let's try this
let's try this ultimate challenge I
think I got it this today earn some
money here we go
so do your worse I think I can host the
crap out of this here we go quick
shout-out to our friends at Direct TV
now for bringing you insider access to
your favorite Kodak configs tired of
being trapped in smothering gear logged
contracts and the cable guys stomping
into your house while he installs some
bulky hardware just so you could watch
your favorite shows well DirecTV now is
dish free with no annual contract no
bulky hardware feel like my life is in
danger
DirecTV now lets you watch your
must-have live TV shows networks and
more from anywhere have 10 or 11 hours
to kill while you wait in line or wander
is set no problem with DIRECTV now you
can stream your favorite shows like the
Conan O'Brien show right from wherever
you are wherever you are and that weight
and that whole ads pic will go by in no
time no matter what you like DirecTV now
has more of your live at Kona con thing
cannot stop me okay keep that huge thank
you to Conan and Andy for same Bible
they'll be back there for the rest of
the show just off camera that is the
most terrifying thing I've ever seen as
he blends into the background huge thank
you too
Conan O'Brien and Andy Richter four more
at your kkona con thing my
correspondents you guys were out there
at the con all day long this is like
this is probably the biggest day right
yeah it was Saturday Saturday people are
off from work gonna con day yeah Oh mark
so they're out there so people that you
know working-class people we're out
there yeah
Joel you went down there all right yes
you were out there would you would you
would you grab for us all right think
I'm gonna start with marina because
you're right here
where's today right I did I checked out
the cosplayers today which was exciting
because there's a little thing that
happened yesterday where I won the
streams yeah like I said because I love
playing God of War but I added an S to
it by accident there you marina
oh my god it is the you know in the
world of things to worry about this is
the most important thing Internet what
you up you know what it is important to
a lot of young gentlemen out there yeah
little boys that really have a lot to
think about and so I apologize I want to
say to the camera I want to say to all
of my young little boys out there I
messed up I'm sorry it's not gods of war
it's goddess of war whoo
singular not plural come at me I'll slap
back oh I think I have a photo of this
so more of your cosplay thing here's
marina down at Convention Center for ya
because it's a new world baby
yeah with you we got we've got a lot of
goddesses they're all fantastic look at
them
Wonder Woman Harley Quinn very popular
just like is it mostly Harley Quinn and
Deadpool guys down there yes a lot of
tunes of Harley Quinn's yeah oh you did
I just saw this young lady she was
generous and this Wonder Woman is
absolutely fantastic flawless her makeup
her skin looked good
Wonder Woman has to have good skin yeah
why is that it's one of her powers
one of her powers it's just radiant skin
yeah you can be distracting to look good
oh yeah someone's like oh my god I love
your lack of crush be boom what's behind
it well put that photo up again what's
what's behind that one Oh what's this
pink thing I'm seeing oh that's a pink
yeah Chewbacca okay a female Chewbacca
if you met her welcome you can make
Chewbacca what I don't it's it's a very
complicated time now so I don't want to
say what Chewbacca is yeah but I you
know if Chewbacca wants to be pink oh
this is made up of all the hats from the
women's March we could say that much
absolutely yes this is a Chewbacca that
was just a pile of laundry
yeah that rolled in and his hats flew
these hats I I've purchased many of
those hats I made them to appeal box in
San Diego so I think now we know where
they ended up mailing those yes yes yes
okay so you were down there you got
another cosplayer I did this is a a lot
of pictures of me because apparently and
I'm not in video form because they don't
want me to talk but this woman right
here this is an example of feminism at
its highest when you don't feed us
mm-hmm this is what happens so this is
maybe like okay this is she's moving to
a second location without getting shot
not not a lot of female gremlins out
there that is a sex-positive gremlin yes
she is look how sexy she is she's giving
me a nice pound two and then we're gonna
go eat some more and yeah after midnight
though right gremlins no not a marina's
intermittent fasting right can't eat
after me not after eight eight are you
doing this intermittent fasting it's
screwed up completely this week right
cuz you're in different time zone I'm on
a different time three hours off I've
been eating and yeah I'm not gonna look
good in my super hero outfit ever again
I don't believe these words you get that
cool jacket yesterday I did blue is into
it thank you for big-time foolin is she
who is she base he's a super Bay Bay Bay
Bay Bay Bay all the base that's right
and there's something else exciting
happened you got two
meet the cast of a new movie yeah this
was the most exciting thing because as
you all know I've been looking to meet a
celebrity all week Joel's been hogging
all the celebrity boy coin it's not Mike
oh yeah down there you were down there
with the star of Wimbledon so today I
met the celebrities of Oh a different
show new movies Shabbat shows am yeah I
don't want to get something at me again
so there's Shazam no more of your movie
thing this is marina down there with the
cast of schism and they were you know
what you meet a lot of actors when
you're talented comedian like myself yes
and I have to say this crew was so much
fun they had the trailer come out today
which is actually hysterical I think of
all the DC stories and look I'm sounding
like I know what I'm talking about I
really don't but of all the DC Comics
stories that have come out this is
supposed to be the brighter of those
series it's dark and that's the best
part and all of the actors they were so
much fun we did a dance but and we and
we spoke but that's not on here the
actress is Zachary Levi
Jack Jack Jill and grazier asher angel
and the director David Sandberg yeah is
that relieved I spoke to me cuz I was
you know I was humbled by him yeah I was
like I'm just a comic and he was like
don't say that you're just a comic
you're slinging those jokes lady you got
the greatest endorsement the comic can
get do you know did they tell you what
this movies about because the trailer
was released today yeah the movie okay
so I'm you know I've tried to retain a
lot of information so you I have to
apologize if I get this wrong but it's
about a young man who's like an orphan
and then he gets these superpowers the
best powers and then he turns into a man
with superpowers sort of like a super
puberty says she celebrated the word he
says whenever he wants to
yes Shazam and then he turns into a full
grown man maybe I should try that I'm
still waiting on puberty to fully drops
maybe a few Shazam's in there yeah now
become a man I touch you oh my god
that's a lot of
I think I'm a man now telling a man now
you look very man technically like a man
yes comments-section disagrees bye thank
you for that legally speaking sorry just
one it's all in the manner in the manner
yes okay did you meet Chuck he's really
not this different
Kazaam that's because that's your bet we
all collectively remember a movie it's
called Shazam starring Shaquille O'Neal
but it did not he did not happen that's
okay would it be excited to see that he
made candy rain from the sky cinematic
as the height of cinematic achievement
yes it's making have you seen Kazaam I
have not and I feel like I am a
disappointment but still well that's
gonna do it for marina goodbye we know
I'm being kicked out of my own community
yes hey you could say that's cool you
got to meet all them yeah nice and very
nice supportive fun I definitely think
the movie is gonna be a blast and funny
that's very cool yeah yeah is there
anything else that your movies what's
your overall opinion so you went in kind
of not knowing what this was kind of
like okay you never been to a comic all
right no I've never been to a Comic Con
I I have a lot of other important issues
in my life but this was I have to say it
was a lot of fun I've learned a lot
which is the most important thing about
this thank you little boys out there
telling me about gods it's so important
to be informed about these things I mean
what would I do if I didn't do what
these young boys teaching us how to win
yeah you've got to read your comic books
yeah would you come back next year
absolutely yeah if you guys will have me
I would love to have you fat and I mean
that in the nicest way I won't come back
unless you're back but that really it's
either both of us or one of us either
any of the jobs oh there's gonna be a
lot in that comment womanís oh we love
it you are posting mean comments once
you send us a quick five-minute clip of
your standup and we'll play it here live
on the show see how that does Flula you
were down there oh you had a picture
yeah there's more bring it
one more picture Lonnie good job and
it's yes I mean we're picturing it's
viral disease at Cornell
we're picturing it up oh this is so cool
so you were down there there was there
was an artist down there that's making
custom drawings yes and his name is hmm
was it Simon
right oh no is it Tom neuen yeah yeah
Tom making and you so you went in there
being like hey you can like request what
you want to be drawn as I actually had a
very helpful assistant who told me that
this would be an amazing experience to
have myself drawn as like animated
character from the comic books and the
she's they he asked me he said what is
the one character you would like to do
and I said what kind of forever you're
the only one on the panel that can do
that I mean you can you can you can do
it no that's that trap that's a trap
Moses writes of trans that's right a
trap don't do it it's a trap let's
support what you say forever I'm here as
an ally here's my safety pin I did the
very least I could do that's so cool so
do you have that they let you keep that
right they let me keep it it was very
expensive thank you again Conan and
leather jacket now this yeah so very
jealous I went down to comic-con is that
can you drop me a Superman they just
dropped me with a giant head in a
go-cart every time well that's your
power I picture you that's my power your
big hit the big head big showbiz head
okay thank you so much that's great
stuff
Shazam I'm a man now too much Flula you
were down there yes
would anyone like a snack before we
start I have a banana
I don't want your wants a marshmallow
very warm
much forever would like a Clementine
it's fresh oh I'm bagging tell you to
put it away my clementines yes oh it's a
chili pepper song put it away put it
away with the waiter whatever you want
to translate that ass just put it away
oh is this your diet you nothing but one
single wilted banana Clementine and and
some crunchy crackers crunchy crackers
marshmallows marshmallows yes very
hopped up yeah people have been loving
your excitement Conan was like you're
almost too excited too much too much too
much booty in the pants dance - yep I
get it I feel like today you went down
there and used it you address this a
problem of too much excitement yes I'm
very excited a day one I did see the
lines and the doors and day two I'm
getting closer and now I'm finally
getting some achievement I hey yes this
I want to talk about because day one
this time it was to go down to comic-con
trouble Oh too early didn't make it in
the troop they - you were like oh I made
it in this is very exciting and then you
were just in the lines yes yeah you got
a little bit further I have seen so many
of the lines and now I've approached the
lines and now we have you know like when
they made a lot of the Rings Return of
the King this is like that so it's like
a sequel or is this a heightening it's a
little too long and there were three
different ending that's right and I fell
asleep twice and maybe photo isn't it
okay so more for your on the floor at
comic-con thing here is fluo
[Music]
this line is really moving the line is
moving quickly so let's see where we are
going so I finally made it through one
of the lines it was everything I dreamed
up okay so no again as another line even
worse this time he ended up in a you
know men's restroom I achieved the end
of the line
okay Moses but I tell you what happened
I met some nice people on the toilet and
I took a photo with them immediately oh
boy you're not supposed to talk to
people it's like an unspoken rule that
you stay in your stall and and nothing
is said I was in the middle of the
toilet and just saying hello everyone
welcome to the end of the lines and good
way to get arrested these men approached
me very quickly so you met people in the
bathroom I did I took a photo would you
like to see it George Michael I really
don't want to see it but okay here's
that's with some bathroom men they were
very friendly
as you can see Wow my shirt is having
many snacks and so I said touch me on
your favorite call behind right that's
that's those are the people from Super
Troopers - what is this that's the cast
and creator of Super Troopers is Jay
Erik Paul Kevin and what and they all
have to pee at the same time I've heard
that I'm a US men's bladders aligned
with you marina you sync up your bladder
yes that's how it goes you guys ready to
go in 30 ready to tinkling Gary oh yeah
yeah by the end of the week hey Moses
would you like to see something no but
we will a single Clementine peel look at
this this will biodegrade 8% faster so
wow thank you
that's good truly so full of wonder fluo
thank you so much
you're very welcome if you married one
of the Super Troopers you would be Moses
stormtrooper wow I saw that coming from
a mile away but yet it hit me with a
surprise a kilometer let's be honest
have you ever felt shame before shame
shame what do you mean like a like a
regret deep regret or an embarrassment
no I have a tattoo on my
at what you call it sunshine the
sunshine spot the sunshine spot yeah the
entire world was made up of fluids we
live in a better place bored I don't
know if I want to live in that world I'm
in time nah no thanks
how fluids gonna eat we have no I'll let
you have that to your joel you were out
there today yeah Moses I got to really
this whole week I I spoke to some real
nerds down at comic-con you know we've
been roasted by them these people
sitting at home watching the live stream
but I got out on the streets and I
talked to some real experts okay these
comic-con more for your on the street
thing here's Joel hi I'm here with disco
for more of your dog thing disco well
what do you think who do you think is
the best batman disco Oh are you Kevin
Costner fan
I'm here with Coco Coco are you having a
good comic-con why do you think it took
so long to get a female doctor who
ant-man Julius
good boy who is the best spider-man in
the franchise Tobey Maguire Andrew
Garfield Tom Holland anime dubbed or
subbed what do you think she likes and
really quickly before the comments
explode yes I did mix up Michael Keaton
and Kevin Costner I got my Costner and
Mike Eaton mixed up disco had me
flustered didn't something happen the
first day - with a fur thin a fair birth
and a feral yeah listen I don't know my
words but I know my heart disco I mean
you saw a disco I got real flustered I
was gonna come in here and try and lie
and pretend like it was two separate
questions who is your favorite Batman ,
do you like yeah Michael Kevin Costner
but ya know I know the Batman's I think
Kevin Costner would be a great Batman
though you've made a full art from day
one was like comedy yeah right yeah day
one he's all about truth yeah what a
full character arc for you really I love
to give people a satisfying narrative
conclusion at the end of these Jack
Reacher yeah Jack Ryan met Jack Reacher
oh that's a totally different coming me
yeah I know right yeah no I the Jack
Ryan experience which is the world's
first fully immersive 4d virtual reality
experience and it was the most intense I
have done in my entire life okay let's
take a look at that
so more for your VR thing here's Joel
yeah so this is they have what's for
dinner egg and they they have you go
this is like very high up they start you
on this obstacle course basically in
shape you jump at you you gotta jump out
of this it and it really does just go to
a CrossFit gym this is just like the
first level of project that's what
you're feeling this was very scary you
know that you're on a board that's like
inches off the ground but it is very
like I was shaking like a leaf this is
this is you touring a Airbnb in Morocco
and you shoot at people on Twitch made
fun of me because I was ducking and
diving like this is
that wasn't listen I'm a I have a
theater degree I was I was suspending my
literally very theatrical zip line there
was just hands up just hey I'm open yeah
I died there did you find him
yeah I met a lot of guys Marina they
were all horny for marina soldier guy
was supposed to act in this and then I I
lost him yeah well I'm just the it's
we're here for one more day I mean I was
gonna go to that thing that you went you
got it yeah if you're still at comic-con
the line is worth it it's the most fun
I've had since I got here will you
comfort with that man screaming at you
in the Jeep you know why I look heated
my entire life has been men screaming at
me and Jeeps so I felt very at home you
know you can give those ubers a bad
rating right oh really
yeah absolutely that's totally
yourself it's hip them right yes yes No
so this is our our last live stream
there's two more Conan shows left
there's not one on tonight most is the
cast and tomorrow is the cast of Aquaman
so since it was the end of the week it
was time for my performance review as a
host in addition to the comment section
my boss gave me a performance review so
more of your kkona Khan thing here's me
get my review hey guys Moses storm here
I'm in Conan's office right now grab
this breakfast theater at this breakfast
theater top and you're on the verge of
losing your voice right now yes those
have been insane those been great I came
down with I have a little
laryngitis and so the doctor this
morning gave me this
prednisone it's a lot of letters and
symbols yeah that's a steroid so I'm
incredibly pumped right now
maybe kicks in like couple hours Wow
okay incredible well Greta will slam on
your party this is a bad start because
it's time for my performance review it's
the end of the week and since you're on
the verge I'm gonna giving you a double
thumbs up double thumbs up and I would
do a triple thumbs up but this is all I
got
you could rape even hilarious funny and
your natural eyes look like they have
eye makeup you look like you're wearing
eyeliner at all times that's incredible
yes they were another guy like that I
sleep with Tubman Potter just over my
eyes like an eye mask it's incredible
I mean just blew that door open and
that's real you can't make that stuff up
it's just hard to the hump if Vicki who
did
you guys do these polls by how I take
tomb right now so stay tuned more we
have a good time tonight some a great
show
bring Saturday night tomorrow you just
threw your friend at me
all right Lots all feeling I think I'm
coming down with whatever you have is
your new performance review oh come on
sorry dude so I think that's pretty
positive
ish I mean it does get me one step
closer to my long-term goal of you know
one day taking over as host of Joker's
wild I love how they find a way to work
debt booty into every category Wow there
is a sense we last left you only what
could be described as a inhumane amount
of smoke up here coming from the tapas
machined I know we teased that yesterday
that there was a just say there's a
tapas restaurant cooked right yeah there
is a vent blowing directly onto a small
plates all right it's not bacon tonight
mathematic are you so now there's
seagulls we're so far from where the
beach should be and there's just hot
smoky Thapa air blowing into our set
what a way to end the week because why
should it be comfortable on a show why
do things indoors why have a live
audience
no get us upon the roofs we have as much
space as possible for the elements to
take control say would word say word so
before we get out of here I understand
we have gifts for each other everyone
was I have to say I got these t-shirts
because you guys are all monstrously
funny okay I thought you're pulling is
like how your back oh cool
you legitimate it fits everyone's
character and this is for Joel yeah so
we hold this up for us so we can see
this and this is for you because you
have three
you do every three heads I was
circumcised twice and they made a huge
mistake
yeah I don't go to a rabbi that has too
much wine at the 100k Thank You Medina
thank you so much very nice I smile
really big this is really our Joel oh me
yes I got you guys each some fun little
Lego brick characters and I got them all
based on so I got you these back to the
future ones because you give me a very
Michael J Fox vibe oh you this jurassic
world Chris Pratt one because he wears a
fanny pack in that movie oh thank you
man and marina I got you a Ghostbusters
one because you ain't afraid of no go so
much before you put that entire Lego set
together and make the most inspiring
content do you have gifts for us what I
mean can you do both at once yes now the
trash is okay guys cool everyone so
please have a hot trash boy through the
sad almost a very serendipitous and
poetic moment to have hot trash blow
through our wonderful set new car cannot
give me a wonderful gift cholans and
expect okay I guess I don't like it I am
passionate about your gift Joe we're
running low on time how can I get these
what you guys all the mullets remember
the mullets from Jersey that is going to
Joe in suitcase I got you this because
you are always screaming words I don't
understand like lime and then I gave
that you and then marina this just I
like it
okay and it's for you
and oh I got this one because it reminds
me of skunks and skunks your thing oh no
watch out it's going to squirt some
black juice on my face but then if you
pet it it's friendly Moses I've said
that multiple times during this
broadcast watch out that thing's gonna
squirt black stuff on my face is
referring to the tapas machine again
that is blowing smoke into our set this
feels like show business this is going
in the overhead yes sure absolutely
I got a gift for all of you guys I've
been down in the groom the greenroom for
most of the time so I actually have a
pretty pretty exciting surprise for you
guys
really the star of the greenroom samuel
l.jackson better bruce willis yes
I'm of course talking about the
untouched sandwiches that no one wanted
the gray and white Manet's and ham
sandwiches with egg whites that have
been sitting out in the room temperature
since 1:00 p.m. do not even those unless
you want to take a gamble on what the
rap party's gonna be I can't eat
anything white sorry look at that I'm
sorry no white for me sandwiches are
made up no carbs conan's complexion
actually I got you guys real gifts it's
even a little bit better I will not I
will not then you think it's gonna be it
tastes like
like you two met it hole it that so like
it tastes like hospital supplies yeah
throw it down the Tongass hole
oh just get it just swallow it Moses and
your palate cleanser where's those
marshmallows oh yeah
marshmallows now just eat the orange
peel guys some Conan shirts than this
you are contractually obligated to wear
these on the streets and tell everyone
that Conan is on tonight with the cast
of glass
Samuel Jackson they're stuck the room
Willis oh oh man what a show where to
show this has definitely become so the
cast of glass is on tonight I have a
entire list of them Bruce Willis Samuel
Jackson
Anya Taylor joy sir
Paulsen an M night Shyamalan all on the
show tonight make sure you're watching
Conan tomorrow
the cast of Aquaman is on Jason moment
Amber her Momo Momo Momo he's not a
museum of modern art Moses storm you are
turning into me Jason Louvre is on
alright Jason Momoa Amber Heard Yaya
Abdul my team got that one right I think
Patrick Wilson and the director James
Wan on the show so make sure you're
watching those shows and make sure
you're following at Konak on all this
stuff we didn't have time for we will be
posting there I want to say a huge thank
you to my correspondents the very sleepy
Joel Kim booster marina Franklin and of
course the Internet's favorite Flula
Borg
I'm Moses storm thank you guys so much
for joining us for these live after
shows we will see you again next year
yes goodbye and good night
[Music]
you